- Oh hello.
I was just warming
myself by the fire.
(log crashing
loudly and hissing)
Welcome to Badass
Bitches of History.
I'm Jenny Zigrino.
My guest today is Anne Hutchin--
(glass crashing and breaking)
- Whooo!
Patriots won!
Wicked!
- I didn't know
you liked football.
- What's football?
- Anne, are you sure
you should be doing that
when you're pregnant?
- I stood up against the
Church, the government,
and I was on trial whilst
bakin' this friggin' bun.
I think I can handle my shit.
- Gross.
- So we doin' this?
Mama's gotta piss
like a racehorse.
- We're here in
17th century Boston,
and Anne Hutchinson is a
mother, she's a midwife--
- And I was wicked smart.
I'm chillin' in the
new colony of Boston,
way before New York was
around 'cause Yankees suck,
and John Winthrop
was the governor.
Also a massive asshole.
- And while she's chillin',
she starts preaching
her own version of the
Bible from her home.
(water splashing)
- Oh shit, my
water's just broke.
(shouting and groaning)
- She actually splits
the colony between people
who believe in a covenant
of grace versus--
(groaning and screaming)
Are you okay?
- Oh, yeah.
(baby crying)
I have 15 of these things.
- That was fast.
- So anyway, my
sermons were the shit.
They were the talk of the town,
but the dudes of Boston have
huge egos and tiny dicks,
so, they got jealous. (sighs)
(gavel hammering loudly)
- We the people of Boston,
meaning the men of Boston,
formally declare Anne Hutchinson
to be guilty of heresy,
and also of kind
of being a bitch.
- Go fuck yourself, Smith!
- Smile wouldn't kill ya, hon.
- I was killin' it
during my trial.
I stood up for
what I believed in,
religious friggin' freedom.
I told those dickheads
off and I almost won too.
- Almost!
Until she said God spoke to her.
(gavel hammering)
- Ha ha!
I gotcha!
God doesn't talk to
women, she is guilty!
- Then they banished her to--
- Rhode Fucking Island.
(door slamming)
- Okay, sure, you got banished,
but we did name a highway
after you in the Bronx.
- Oh yeah yeah,
real friggin' honor,
having my road in the same
borough as Yankee Stadium?
That was the real
friggin' punishment.
- But Anne, you inspire
people who fight for truth
and justice--
- Yeah yeah yeah,
you seen my kid?
I was just--
Oh never mind, it's cool,
I'll make a new one.
- It's not too bad,
look, lobster rolls,
and there's one big city.
Look at that, there's
a guy in a boat!